entre tanto vamos a hablar de las
noticias de economía con Daniela Blandón
Daniela saludo para usted Hola Ángela y
hacemos la actualización el Banco
Central europeo subió las tasas de
interés pues no dio sorpresas cumplió
con su promesa de Elevar Estos tipos de
interés en medio punto porcentual para
seguir combatiendo la inflación óptima
obstinadamente alta en este continente
hasta hace una semana el mercado daba
por descontada esta decisión no había
sorpresa sin embargo muchos pensaban que
iba a cambiar de opinión a último
momento por el caos del mercado
financiero de esta semana y todos los
llamados que han hecho los
inversionistas para reducir el
endurecimiento de la política al menos
hasta que se estabilice la confianza en
el sistema financiero así las cosas este
Banco Central que rige a los 20 países
que comparten el euro elevó su tasa de
depósito al 3% este es el nivel más alto
desde finales de 2008
Daniela
la decisión no se produce en medios del
caos que generó el segundo mayor banco
de Suiza esta noticia ya la hemos
conversado y ese Pues bien interesante
Claro porque el Banco Nacional Saudita
que tiene un 10% en el gigante Credit
Suiza y es su principal accionista el
miércoles causó revuelo tras decir que
no iba a invertir más dinero en la
entidad porque La regulación no se lo
permite pues esto lo que hizo fue que la
acción de del crédito en la bolsa de
zúrich se desplomara el miércoles a
menos de dos Franco suizos algo que no
había pasado en su historia pero ya
revirtió la tendencia esta madrugada se
conoció que el Banco Nacional suizo le
va a hacer un préstamo por cerca de 54
mil millones de dólares y su acción sube
más del 20%
bueno Daniela ahora le quiero pedir con
estas dos informaciones que me entrega
Pues cómo se expresan los indicadores
pues las bolsas asiáticas cayeron con
fuerza antes de todas estas noticias
todos estaban muy pendientes de Europa
de hecho en este continente las bolsas
suben a la espera Pues de cómo van a
asimilar esta noticia del Banco Central
europeo También estamos pendientes de la
apertura de Wall Street y hay que decir
también que el principal índice de la
bolsa de París opera al alza en este día
clave como lo estábamos conversando con
Luis Miguel para el proyecto de reforma
pensional estamos pendientes entonces de
la aprobación en la asamblea nacional y
de eso dependerá cómo se comporte
también los inversionistas en París
sabemos que en el Reino Unido ha habido
constantes huelgas del personal
sanitario y parece que por fin le podría
verse una solución en el camino al tema
Pues el ministro de economía ayer se
había mostrado confiado en que lograría
un acuerdo salarial con los trabajadores
de la salud y la prensa local británica
Ya habla de que sí lo hubo los empleados
del servicio nacional de salud Estatal
que fueron ovacionados por su labor
durante la pandemia ahora exigen mejores
salarios en medio de una inflación anual
que ya es de dos dígitos y es la más
alta de la región y finalmente el
presidente de los Estados Unidos anunció
que va a poner en cintura algunas de las
farmacéuticas por el alza de los precios
Sí señora pues el mandatario viajo a
Nevada el miércoles para promover su
plan para reducir los costos de atención
médica por medio de más impuestos a las
personas con altos ingresos allá anunció
que obligará a las grandes farmacéuticas
a reducir el costo de los medicamentos
que subieron de precio por encima de la
inflación en los últimos dos años esta
medida entonces Aplica para los mayores
de 65 años que forman parte del sistema
de salud público Medicare es decir unas
60 millones de personas estas empresas
van a tener que bajar los costos de un
grupo de 27 fármacos entre los que se
encuentran anticoagulantes o fármacos
antibacterianos a partir del próximo
primero de abril y así se refirió el
presidente a esa noticia y también
quisiera pedirle temas de América Latina
para hacer un completo repaso
de Panamá comienza hoy una reunión bien
importante Así es el banco
interamericano de desarrollo tiene 48
países miembros y desde hoy y hasta el
sábado se reúnen en Ciudad de Panamá
líderes económicos y financieros
especialmente de América Latina y del
Caribe enfrentan la coyuntura del
colapso de los bancos en Estados Unidos
la repentina caída del banco silicon
Valley Bank uno de los mayores colapsos
bancarios en la historia de Estados
Unidos ha disparado las dudas sobre la
salud del sector y también los temores a
una nueva crisis financiera pues previo
encuentro el presidente del pib Y lean
golfeng subrayó que latinoamérica tiene
un sistema financiero muy resiliente y
que cree que está preparado ante
posibles efectos negativos también habló
de la agenda de esta semana bueno pues
Hoy tuvimos
Cómo resolver este desafío de mucha
demanda sociales con pocos recursos y la
necesidad de que sea Entonces nosotros
vamos a abordar esos temas en la reunión
anual así como las otros temas que
enfocan por ejemplo en las ficciones
sociales el cambio climático la
biodiversidad vamos a hablar de
infraestructura tanto física y digital y
vamos también a hablar de cómo aumentar
la publicidad a mejorar el crecimiento
Pues bueno este es el completo reporte y
resumen de las noticias económicas de
hoy Daniela finalizamos Ya esta etapa y
nos vemos mañana mañana nos vemos con
más información económica